[音楽]で 今日は人間とうまく付き合う方法
その二 二部なんですね
前回で一応論理的に基本的なところを説明いたしました
いわゆる科学的に 心理学的にどんなからくりがありますかと
生命の間では で それだけ理解すれば
まあすべての問題は解決しますけど
それでもまあ少々実践的に我々はどのように人々と付き合うべきかということも
あのお聞きになりたいだろうと思ってますし
そういうことで 今日はいわゆる応用編ですか
実践編ですか そこら辺に少々お話しさせていただきます
話終わったところで 皆様方は私にいろいろ具体的な質問をなさってください
それぞれの人間関係は違いますから
私の人間関係と それぞれの皆様方の人間関係はそれぞれ違いますので
私にすべてまとめて喋るということは決してあり得ない話なんです
で 私は知ってる人々と皆様方
ご存知な方々 付き合ってる方々はまあそれぞれ違いますので
性格も生き方も そういうことで
人間関係の応用編というのは
一人の人に全部まとめて喋るということは決してできない
あり得ないことです ですから
いくらか話をまとめるために
補うために 皆様方ご自分の問題
ご自分が人と付き合って失敗したことやら困ったことやら
どうすればいいかと この場合はどうすればいいかという何かございましたら
それをどうぞ遠慮なしに言ってください
私はできるだけ一般的な一般論として答えます
できるだけ具体的にこうしなさいということはできるだけ避けて
一般的に答えますので
遠慮なしに聞いてください
で じゃあこれからこの今日の話でどうすればうまく人と付き合えますかということ
まず申し上げたいのは
それは世の中でやる一番とても難しいことなんです
人と付き合うことはとても難しいんです
仏教では修行して心を清らかにして悟るという大胆な道を教えていますけど
それもできますよ 一人で頑張れば
悟ることさえできるんですよ
皆様方にその気にさえあれば
でも それよりも人とうまく付き合うということはとても難しいんです
それまず覚えておいてください
修行して心を完全に清らかにして解脱することよりも
人間とうまく馬が合ってうまく付き合うということはそれより難しいんです
じゃあ その覚悟があった上で話を進めなくちゃいけないんです
お分かりになるだろうと思います
ですから 今日から言う方法も結構難しいかもしれません
実践するのは 難しく実践したっても完璧でないかもしれません
それだけ覚えておいてください
なぜそんなことを申し上げますかというと
たまに人間付き合いで
もうたまに失敗したっても
たまに間違いがあっても
話が通じなくても 馬が合わなくても
違う線路に行ってしまっても
それほど気にする必要はないんです
それほど自分を責めることはないんです
例えば 親の希望通りに子供はうまくいかないと
だからといって自分を責めたりする必要はないんです
あり得ることなんです
夫婦の間の考え方 生き方がどんどん分かれていって
違う道に行くかもしれません
だからといって いちいちそのことについて悩む必要はないんです
それはもう 90%あり得ることで
うまくいくのは大変難しいんです
ですから 私たちはだいたい子供の時からも大人になって死ぬ時までも人と付き合いますし
常にこの人間付き合いの中で常にいろいろ失敗
過ちを起こしているんです
そんなことは全くないという人は絶対ありませんといませんと私は思っています
ありえないと それで人間付き合うことで
人と付き合うことで すごい失敗なことをしましたと
恥ずかしいことをしましたと
自分を責めたり 悩んだり落ち込んだりすると
もうキリがないんです
キリがないんです ですから
あ これ失敗か じゃあ今度頑張るぞと
そんな気持ちで頑張らなきゃ
まず人間とうまく付き合えない
それは第1 じゃあ繰り返し申し上げますけど
まああっちこっち失敗があっても
あまり気にしないこと
くよくよしないこと あり得るものはありましたと
まあしょうがないんだと
他のところで頑張ります
他の方で その失敗過ちをくよくよしないで
一つの勉強にして 明るくポジティブ的に前向きに生きていれば結構です
ですから 次に申し上げたいのは
決して完璧に人々と付き合って
すべて万事解決してうまくいってほしいという希望があるならば
それだけは捨ててください
決して自信があって人と付き合うもんじゃないんです
ですから 皆様方はすごく自信あってほしいんですね
生き方には 私は逆を言いたいんですね
自信がない方が正しいんだと
我々は生きる時は 人と付き合う時はどうすればいいかと
さっぱり自信がないんだと
この自信がない方が健康的で普通で正しいんです
あまり自信があったら
それで失敗を起こすんです
失敗をするんです ですから
次のポイントは 人と付き合う場合はいつでも自信がない状態で
心を持った方がいいんです
うまくいくかなと こんな話したっても
うまく通じるかなと 理解してくれるかなと
もしかすると理解しないだろうと
もしかすると誤解するだろうと
そういう不安で そういう自信のない状態で人と付き合ってみてください
もう一応私はお願いしてこれ言いたいんです
普段言わない話なんです
普段の世界ではすごく自信があって生きることを喋ってるんです
あれは非科学的で非合理的なんです
どのように人間に自信がつけますかね
このような世間で 人間というのは自分のことをさえわからないんです
皆様方に聞きたいんです
我々は私の心の働きを知ってますかと
私の心 どのように働いているかと知ってますか？私はいつ怒るか
いつヒステリーになるか
いつ感情的になるか いつ落ち込むか
いつ明るくなるか そういうことを知ってますかね
知らないでしょうに それで次に
自分には自己コントロールありますかね
私はこの場合で感情的にはなりません
この場合では絶対泣きません
この場合では絶対笑いませんと
この場合は絶対落ち込まないんだと
この場合は絶対怒りませんと
という自信ございますか？自己コントロールできますか？できないでしょう
何かいいことあったらすぐ笑っちゃう
すぐ楽しくなる 何か 悪いことに出会ったらすぐ怒る
悲しくなる 何かやったことを失敗したらすぐ落ち込んでしまう
人に何か言われたら 自分の失敗を示されたらすぐ恥ずかしくなる
プライド傷つく それはないんですかね
我々には いつでもあるんです
ということは 私たちに私の心さえ管理できない
自由自在ではありません
心さえ 自分の心さえ自分の勝手で行動しているんです
ですから うまく人と付き合えると
うまく人の心のコントロールできると思い思うならば
それは不可能なことで
ありえないことなんです
ですから 自信がない方が安心で安全で
間違いはすごく少なくなるんです
それはずっと持ち続けるべきなんです
旦那さんが奥さんと何年一緒に生活して
あ 自分の妻だから大丈夫やとほっとしたら落ち着いたら
後でもう離婚してしまっちゃうんですね
あるいは二人とも何考えてもお互いに互いにわからなくなっちゃうんです
奥さんの場合も同じなんです
あの人は心配ないやと安心しちゃったら
どこでどうなるかわからないんですね
心っていうのはそんなもんなんです
ですから たとえ結婚している夫婦であろうか
毎日相手方の心はどうなることかとわからない状態で
ちょっと心配と不安な状態でいた方が間違いは起こさないんです
人間関係で 高慢にならないんです
余計な自信ができちゃって
言いたい放題のことを相手方には言わないんです
そういうことで ずっと長くうまく互いに馬が合って生きていられるんです
なぜそういうことを言いますかというと
我が心さえ私の支配下にいませんとありませんとという論理からなんです
それはお釈迦様の言葉でございまして
我が心とは自分の心を自分のコントロールにはもう関係なく勝手に行動しているんです
いわゆるわかりやすく釈尊が自分には自分もありませんと
というふうにおっしゃっているんです
ですから 人間関係っていうのは終わりない
キリがない修行なんです
その修行は死ぬまでやらなくちゃいけないんです
釈尊おっしゃった悟りの修行はもうちょっと真面目に頑張ればすぐ終了できるんです
それで生命として解脱しましたと落ち着くことはできるんです
でも 残念ながら人と付き合うことだけは終了ない修行なんです
終了ない 卒業ない教育なんです
卒業する 卒業するということはなし
ずっと頑張らなくちゃいけない
悪い例かもしれませんだけど
曹洞禅禅宗で言ってるような
まあ修行はずっと続けるもんだと
座禅は終わりがないんだと
というふうな  それは違う意味で言ってますけど
まあ音楽もありますね
今日は で ずっと終わりなく続く修行だと覚えておいてください
じゃあそういうのは基本的な人間関係の大変であることをと
どうすればいいかということを両方おっしゃってくれると思います
じゃあ思い浮かぶ順番で
正しい順番ではなくて
実践的なとこをまた時間も計算しながら喋りますので
思い浮かぶ順番で言います
で 大事なポイントを忘れるかもしれません
まあ大体そんなもんです
話終わったら やっぱり一番言いたいポイントは全部忘れたんじゃないかなということになりますから
まず またちょっと基本的なこと
お釈迦様がこういうふうなことを言うんです
サッベータサンティダンラッセ
ちょっとしたお釈迦様の言葉ですから
これ原文なんです  1 行目はサッベータサンティダンラッセ
サッベーっていうのは
すべての生命が サッベー
すべての生命が 動詞はすぐに来るんです
英語と似ていて怖がります
恐怖感感じるんだ 震えるんだ
震えてしまう 確かというのは怖くて体が震えることを足さんって言います
複数形です 怖くて震えます
ダンラッセ 罰 罰せられること
裁かれること パニッシュメント
すべての生命が罰せられること
裁かれること 怖がって震えるんだと
そこでもう少々 ちょっと話はちょっと横道にいくかもしれませんが
もう少々説明させていただきます
この 最後の言葉 ダンデ
パニッシュメント 罰することというのは
いろいろ罰があるんですね
人を叱る 批判する これはいけないという説教する
そういうのを何か過ちを犯しちゃったら
もう別に体罰はしませんだけど
ずっと説教する 二度とそんなことをするな
そんなことをしてはいけないとか
それも罰なんです あるいは批判する
あんたはやることはあまりまあこうだとか
それも罰なんです あれはいろいろ刑法に基づいて刑法というんですか
法律に基づいて ありとあらゆる罰がございます
それから学校は学校なりに罰を決めてある
会社は会社なりに決まってある
社会はそれなりにいろいろ罰を決まっている
法律は 政府はそれなりの罰を決まっている
それで友達同士でもそれあるんです
仲間同士でもあるんです
人間というのはいつでも他人を裁く
何かをすることを作っちゃうんです
ちょっとした仲間のグループを作ったっても
そこに決まりができちゃって
それを犯しちゃったらダメよとと言って
たまにもう仲間同士だったらぶん殴ったりまでするんですよ
若者なんかは あるグループに入っちゃったら
ちょっとでもそのグループの言うことを聞かなかったら
ぶん殴ったり ひどい目に遭わせたりまでするんです
そのように世の中で我々はいつでも罰せられる環境にいるんです
子供も両親のところで幸福でいられますかというと
そうじゃないんです 両親にありとあらゆる批判される
厳しく説教される いろいろパニッシュメントがあるんです
じゃあ お互いの全く同じ平等な同士だから
夫婦間ではそれまたあるんです
ということは 我々は常に罰せられる
裁け 裁かれる環境に来ているんです
でもそれは気持ちいいものですかというと
全く違うんです ものすごくそれ嫌なんです
もし皆様方 批判されるのは好きで好きでしょうがない人がいらっしゃるならば
どうぞ違いますよと言ってください
堂々と罰せられるのは
裁かられるのは大変好きで
もう刺激的でしょうがないんだと
バカにされるのは気持ちよくてとかね
何やってもこれはダメ
あれはダメって言われるのは好きな人がいますか？お釈迦様は全ての生命
人間だけではなくて 一切の生命が罰せられるのは嫌いだよと怖がっているんだよとと言っているんです
それこそ真理なんです
自分の心に聞いてみてください
それは嫌ですね 聞いてみたら
人に裁かれるのはどんな人であろうか
たとえ自分の母親であろうか
叱るのは嫌で好きですか？今日は母に叱られてすごい元気になった
気持ちよくなったとか
嫌でしょうに ですから
罰を受けるのは 裁く 裁かられるのはとても嫌なものなんです
それで私は何を言いたがっているんですか？もうちょっと違うことを言いたがっているんですね
かえって私たちは人を罰するのは
裁くことは大変気持ちよく
元気になって 偉そうにやっているんじゃないんですか
人を批判する時の元気な顔
明るい顔 あの態度 神様みたいに
それみんなそういう性格なんです
それで文句を言うんです
人間関係うまくいかないんだと
うまくいくわけないでしょうに
大変困っているんだと
会社ではいろいろもう大変問題があるんだと
もう仕事を辞めたいんだと
旦那さんとうまくいかないんだと
子供がいなければもう離婚してしまい
しまいたいほどですよとか
というふうに 人間関係うまくいかない
うまくいかないとまた泣き叫んでいる
その泣き叫ぶより まず自分に聞いてください
我々は堂々と ものすごいもうでっかい態度で人を裁くんです
他人を裁くんです 他人を批判するんです
他人に罰を与えているんです
いろんな形で これ 法律に基づいて 10万円罰金とか
そんなことじゃないんです
それより この無視されること
ちょっといじめられること
もっと心に響くんです
例えば お嫁さんがご飯炊いて
旦那さんと子供の分だけ炊いて
全部終わってもう置いておくんだと
そうすると お姑さんがご飯を食べようと思ったらご飯がない
姑さんがもっと上手ですから
さっさとご飯炊けますけど
あれはすっごく心に響くんですよ
あれはぶん殴ったよりはきつい批判であって
罰なんです 具体的に見ればどうったことないんです
自分でご飯炊いて食べればいいし
外置いて食べればそれで物事済みますけど
でも あれはものすごい強烈な罰
人を馬鹿にすること そういうものは我々は毎日何のことなくやっているんです
人を無視することも罰なんです
人を馬鹿にすることもものすごいきつい精神的な罰なんです
この法律ではそれほどやってないんです
法律はまあ物質的にまあなんとか何とか決めるだけで
10万円罰金だよと  10万円払っちゃえば
はい OK 帰ってくださいと終わっちゃうんですよね
心まで攻めようとしないんです
でも 人間が体だけじゃなくて
心まで責めていじめてむちゃくちゃにしてやろうと思っているんです
それまた自分の周りの人々なんですよ
関係ない人にそれできませんから
例えば 電車に乗って 自分が全く知らない関係ない人に何か言ってみてください
とんでもない結果になるんですね
ですから 自分の周りの自分と離れられない人々に
そういうふうな恐ろしい罰を与えているんです
我々はコラやらバカ野郎やらいろんな言葉を言うのは
自分の親しい人々になんです
腹が立ってストレス溜まっちゃって
人に馬鹿野郎とかぶん殴りたいんだったらね
道書いて誰か知らない人にぶん殴ればいいんだけど
それはしませんね 自分のこと怖いんだから
ですから 人間っていうのはどれほど残酷な生活をしているかと
恐ろしいんです ですから
こういうことなんです
自分が批判されるのは嫌であるならば
無視されるのは嫌であるならば
裁かれるのは嫌であるならば
なぜそれを他人にするんですか
何の理由もないんです
ですから その 1 行から言います
いかなる理由あろうとも
人を批判すること 罰すること
裁くこと 徹底的にやめますと
できればもう OK なんです
何の人間関係の問題なくなっちゃうんです
できればやってみてください
わずかにでも相手の気持ちを悪くなること
傷つくことしないんだと
それはバツだと これ たまにちょっともうぶん殴ったっても
あんまり気にしないんです
特に男の場合はね まあ何やってるんですかって
ちょっとぶん殴ったっても
まあそれ全然もうそんなことは気にしない
でも我々はそれよりは精神的に自分の親しい人々
自分の周りの人々 自分の会社の人々は精神的に徹底的にいじめているんです
徹底的に殺しているんです
それをやめてくださいと
それは 1 行目で お釈迦様はそういう真理を語っているんです
それから 2 行目で サッベーサンジーリタンピアン
サッベーサンサッベーサンというのは
すべての生命にジービタン
自分の命をピアン とてもかわいいと
とても好きと 好きなものであると
すべての生命に我が命が可愛いものですと
それはすべての生命に
人間だけではないんです
我が命はとても可愛いものなんです
じゃあ その行で我々何をおっしゃっているんですか？私のことを言っているんですね
私は私の命 私は私を一番好きなんです
ちょっとしたストーリーいます
このお釈迦様の生きていた時
お釈迦様に一応信仰していた王様たちがほとんど信仰していましたから
一番力強い 大きな ものすごいでっかい国のコーサラ国でしたけど
当時の名前で で コーサラ国の王様が国が大きいんだから
よく戦争して隣の国々を捕まえたりするし
ですからお釈迦様のこと信じているんだけど
あまり立派な仏教の信者さんではなかったんです
いわゆる他の王様たちは結構修行でもして
瞑想でもして もう悟りでも一段階まででも開いていたんです
この人はそうではなかったんです
ただ お釈迦様が好きで
仏教は好きで 仏教は信仰している
で その人にものすごく好きなお妃がいたんです
マンリカという たくさんの妃がいたんだけど
このマンリカ夫人のことはものすごく好きなんです
気に入っているんです
美しいし 性格は抜群に綺麗
よくいいんです どういうことかというと
このマリが夫人がものすごい信仰深い敬虔なお釈迦様の信者さんなんですね
ですから よく仏教を勉強して
よく説法を聞いて その通りに謙虚で生きているんです
ですから 誰から見ても何一つも文句を言うところがないんです
そういうことで 王様から見ればもう素晴らしい人で
わがままでもないし すごい謙虚で
献身的にもう何だかんだもしてあげる
お妃だからといって王様いじること
いじめることとか全くなく
人の気持ちを考えて で
大阪王様がですから 勝手に好きで好きでしょうがない
それである日 この二人が一緒に座って話しているんですね
話していると 王様がこう聞くんですね
あなたはこの世の中で一番好きなのは誰ですか？と
王様はお妃のことをすごく好きで
そう聞くんですね ですから
王様だから 国王だから
誰に聞いても どんな人に聞いても
あなたはこの国で一番好きな人は誰ですか？それはもう言うまでもなく王様ですよと言うんですよ
怖いんだから ですから
王様には自信があったんですね
自信があって まあそれは夫婦の会話ですけどね
国王の会話ではなくて
君は一番好きな人は誰ですか？と
そしたらマリカ奥様が何のことなく
そうですね 私はこの世の中で一番好きなのは私ですよと
すっぱりと答えたんです
言ったら 王様の顔がずっと暗くなってしまっちゃったんです
そこでマリカ夫人というのは大変素晴らしい頭のいい方で
嘘は言わない お釈迦様からかなりもう話を聞いてるんだから
そこで王様の気持ちが悪くなったと
それはもう何とか直さなくちゃいけない
でも だからといって嘘を言うわけにもいきません
私は王様のこと大好きですよと
王様のためにもう死んでも悔しくはないんですよとか
そんな丸見え嘘は言いたくないんです
ですから こう聞くんです
じゃあ王様に聞きますけど
王様が正直に答えるならば
この世の中で一番好きなのは誰ですかと
そうしたら王様も正直に考えたんですね
考えちゃったら ああ やっぱり私も一番好きなのは私のことですねと
それで夫婦喧嘩なしに問題は解決したんです
それはお経の中にまで入ってる話なんです
ということは 我々はいかに互いに嘘をついているんですかと
あの人がなければもう生きる意味がないんだとか
あの人がもうなければもう自殺しますよとか
そういう嘘ばっかりついて嘘の世界に生きているんですよ
結局自分が自分のことを好きなんです
ですから サッベーサンジービタンピアン
すべての生命に自分の我が命をとても好きですよと
ですから なぜ私は我々は他人を裁いたり批判したりするんですかというと
それは自分のことを好きだから
自分だけいれば結構じゃないかと
自分だけ幸福であれば結構じゃないんですかと
自分のことを考えてやっているんですね
例えば うちの人 誰かが何か間違いを起こしちゃったと
それで自分が困るんですね
自分が困るんだから ものすごくうるさくいちいち批判したり
説教したりするんです
それで嘘まで言うんだ
あなたのために言ってるんですよと
あれは大嘘で 自分のために言ってる
私は困りますよと あなたはおわけしたら私は困りますよと
あなた子供に対してあなたは万引きしちゃったら私が困りますよと
恥ずかしくてとか それは事実なんですけど
で そう言うんですね あなたのために言ってるんだよと
人のために言ってるならばすぐ聞くんです
私だったら言い方違うんです
例えば私のところにいる人が
例えば万引きするならば
私は万引きして見つかったら万引きしたの？いいでしょ
じゃあ毎日やってください
別に私に関係ないんだからね
君がやりたければ 楽しければどうぞやってくださいと
本当のことを言うんです
私に私がじゃないんだから
そう言われると その人は自分の責任で考えるんです
本当にこれでいいんですかと
他人を困らせ 母親を困らせようとして万引きしたんだけど
母親は全然困りませんだからね
結局バカ見るのは私ですから
私は私のこと好きだから
じゃあ今日からやめますということになるんです
もう二度とやらないんです
嘘を言うんだから聞いてくれない
さっべさんじいびたんぴゃん
それ覚えておいてください
私たちは私たちのことをとても好きですよということは
そこでアッターナウとマンカッタ
アッターナっていうのは
あ すいません アッターナ
自分をウパマンたとえにして
自分をたとえとしてとって
アッターナン自分を ウパマンというのは
たとえ例 自分を例にハットはしてまた進むのです
それではね はねいやね
ガートいや ね はねいや
だいたいこのはねいやね
ガテ言葉 2つもおなじみなんですね
いわゆるいじめる いじめてはいけない
さばいてはいけない 殺してはいけない
暴力振るってはいけないという意味なんですね
文字の意味は殺す 殺してはいけないという意味なんですけど
でもいろんな意味で使うんです
人をいじめること 人を批判すること
人の気持ちを傷つくこと
どんな意味でもその動詞使ってます
動詞 2つあるんです で
聖書みたいに殺すなかれとお釈迦様は言いません
それはすぐ その場合もお釈迦様の素晴らしいことっていうのは
あなた他人をいじめるなとは言わないんです
それは説教だから お釈迦様が言うのはいじめない方がよろしいですよと
という意見を述べるだけ
その違う動詞あるんです
命令形 命令形ではなはなてなガータヤというなんですね
そのためにちゃんと下部が成り立ちますよ
あるいはマハナとマーガータヤと言った方が
詞がちゃんと成り立つんです
詞のしきたりあるんです
決まりが その決まりは成り立ちますけど
お釈迦様はわざわざと
この英語でオプテティブケースというんです
この動詞の使い方は  IT is better if you do not harm it is bett
er if you do not kill という
殺さない方がいいんじゃないか
いじめない方がよろしいんじゃないかという
すごい優しい言葉なんです
ですから お釈迦様は自分をおっしゃることはちゃんと実行するんです
お釈迦様さえ人に人を批判すると
人をバカにすると 他人に他人
それすごく嫌がりますよと知ってるんです
ですから お釈迦様はこう言うんです
自分をたとえにして見てください
自分のこと 自分の心をたとえにしてみたら
見て 他人をいじめない方がいいんじゃないか
他人を非難 非難しない方がいいんじゃないんですかという教えなんです
ですから それを実行していただいただければ
もう問題はないんです
ですから こういうどういう生き方かと申し上げると
私は批判されるのは嫌ですから
私はなぜ他人を批判するんでしょうかと
私は私をバカにするのはされるのは嫌ですから
他人をもバカにはしませんと
私をけなされるのは嫌ですから
私も他人をけなしませんと
いわゆる私を中心にして世の中を見る
私のためにではなくて
あなたのためにと言いながら
本当は私のためにと ですから
もっとわかりやすく言えば
他のいろんな文献でも出てきますけど
自分にしてほしいことは他人にしなさいと
自分にしてほしくないことは他人にもするなという諺に入っているのは同じ意味なんですね
他人が自分にしてほしいことは
自分が他人にしてあげる
他人が自分にしてほしくないことは
決して他人に自分もしてあげない
しない そのように自分をコントロールする
そこからこの人間 この前の話に飛ぶ
飛んでしまう恐れがありますけど
この人間関係で大変大事なポイントというのは
生命すべてが平等であるということなんです
偉い人は一人もいません
生命としてみんな同じなんです
虫もアリも人間も神様も何だかんでも同じなんです
みんな自分のことを好きなんです
聖書を読んでみてください
神様は一番好きなのは自分のことなんです
一番心配しているのは自分のことなんです
聖書で堂々と書いてあるんだから
皆様はどのように読んでいるかわかりませんだけど
私は読んだところで この方も自分のことを大変心配しているんだと
ですから やっぱり親切に考えなくちゃいけないんだと思って
親切に考えて聖書を読んだんです
すごい心配なんです それは見えるんです
まあまあ どうせ神の言葉じゃなくて人間が書く言葉だから
やっぱり人間というのは自分のことを好きなんですよ
神の言葉っていうのは世の中にあるわけじゃないし
まあちょっとした人間がいろいろ考えて書くもんだからね
別に大したことないんですけど
人間が書いたというならば立派なこと
聖書も立派な作品なんです
神の言葉というならば
ただのくだらないもんなんです
あれぐらいのことです
であるならばね 神に言われるのは大した神じゃないんです
ですから もし私はすごく聖書は評価しますけど
それに評価するのは それは人間が書いたと思うと
もう結構立派な人々がいたもんですねとかね
昔はと よくも立派に書いたんですねとか
いまだにもう読めるんだから
あのテキストは 他の小説とかね
ちょっと 10年経っちゃうと
もう時代遅れで読めないんです
味がないんです ですから
まあどんな人間でも どんな時代経っても
やっぱり読めるもん書いてるんだから
もうさすが人間が書いたと思うと
もう本当にすごい人間なんですね
ですから まあでも人間が書いたんだから
やっぱりこの論理はちゃんと入ってるんです
自分のことは心配だと
ですから 生命は平等 平等であるという釈尊の考え方はそのままなんです
それは変わりがない ですから
生命は平等であって そのその生命が自分の命がとても可愛がっていて
それで私たちは他の生命と付き合いたいと
言うならば いつでも同格と呼ぶんですか
同等なレベルでしか付き合うことは不可能なんです
たとえ犬と付き合っても
同格で同等なレベルでしか付き合えないんです
ただの犬ではないかと
ただの野良猫ではないかと
冗談じゃないんです ただの野良猫だと思って
野良猫に石を投げたり
いろいろことをやってみてください
確実に襲撃もされるんです
当然かすかすのは猫の方ですけどね
ですから どんな生命見たっても
我々の心の中になんとなく尊いような気持ちが生まれてほしい
あれは私の子供だと あれは私の妻だと
そんな軽々しく思うもんじゃないんです
あれは私の学校の生徒たちですよとかね
私は先生だからと あれは私の会社の部下ですね
という感じで 偉そうに命令ばっかりして
それで人間関係全部崩れちゃうんです
ですから 仏教から申し上げるならば
どんな生命見たっても
大変尊い平等な一人の生命として
自分と全く同じレベルの生命として心で見なくちゃいけない
そうすると 相手の権利を奪うことは全くあり得ない
それで完璧な人間関係できるんです
人間だけじゃなくて すべての生命と完璧にうまくいくんです
誰も自分をいじめようとしないんです
だからみんな口先だけで
まあ平等だ平等と言うんだけど
全然実行してないんではないんですか
例えば まあこれは言ってはいけないことなんですけど
この頃でいまだに男女差別はあるんじゃないんですか
人々を差別しているんではないんですか
人間の心からいつこの差別感消えるかと
私は本当に考えますよ
たまに 私はあまり人を攻撃しませんだけど
わずかにでも差別感があって喋っちゃうと
ものすごく腹が立って立ち上がるんです
鬼みたいに とことん責めるんです
その時だけ その時は覚悟して
相手はとの気持ちはとことん傷ついてほしいんです
わざとバカにするんです
別にその人はわからない
なんで別に大したこと言ってないのに
そんなにいちいち言うんですかと
それは大したこと言ってない人本人思ってるかもしれません
でも僕に感じちゃうんですね
その人は他の生命をバカにしているんだと
それはけしからんのだ
それは絶対あってはいけないことだと
どんな子供であろうか
動物であろうか 差別しては絶対いけないんです
人間というのは差別する
差別 民衆差別 国ごとに差別
白人と黒人を差別 それモンゴル人系とまた他の人々
また差別と で まあ本当の話
これは批判になりますから
本当は申し訳ないんだけどね
で よく差別するんですよ
他人を それは自分と何とか違うと思うことを差別なんです
あの人お嫁さんだからとと思う瞬間にもう差別しているんです
他の家から来た人だということで
それでうまくいかないんです
一番人間の心はものすごい嫌ということは差別なんです
差別は嫌なんですけど
我々は他人を平気で差別する
だから たとえキリスト教にしたっても
すごい差別なんですね
神が人間にだけ魂を吹き込んじゃうんですね
動物にやってないんですね
冗談じゃないんです あれ
動物差別してることじゃないんですか？それであの旧約聖書ですか
これはもう神様がありがたくて
あなたのことはとごく慈悲で
愛情があって もう人間に食えるために動物なんか作ってくれたんだと
私は作ったんだだから空の空を飛ぶ鳥と
鱗入ってる川のいる魚と
吐いて食べる動物食いなさいと命令するんですね
それで吐いて食べることと
この足のあれ なんて言いますか
ほふ 蹄 蹄 ついてる動物は食いなさいと
でも豚は吐いて食べないんだから豚は食うなと
これ旧約聖書なんですけど
あんなものを読むとね
まあまあ 神は別に信じて僕は信じてないんだから
別に腹が立つことはないんだけど
あれは当時の人間が 特にユダヤ系の人々は豚肉を食べない
なんか嫌いと不浄だと思っているんだから
まあただそれだけの理由で言ってることなんですが
それでも宗教の言葉として見るならば
そこに人間だけ偉くて
動物は偉くないんだと
そこでクリスマスなんか出てくると
もう殺されるは殺されるは動物
感謝のなんとかってありますね
サンクスギビングデーとか
かわいそうに あのなんとかなんとか鳥
ターキー うん 日本語で何て言います？七面鳥
七面鳥をちゃんと育てて
その日はみんな殺しちゃうんですね
もし私が聞きたいのは
もし神様がそう決めたならば
そのサンクスギビングデーになってくると
感謝の日では七面鳥たちが殺されたくて殺されたくて
どうぞ殺して食べてくださいと待ってるはずなんですね
豚を殺そうと思ったら
豚は自分で勝手に出てきて
はい 殺してちょうだいと
召し上がってくださいと言うはずなんですよ
豚は殺すとものすごい悲鳴ですか
もう聞いていられないほど悲しく泣くんです
必死で命を守るために逃げるんです
生命はみんな同じなんです
アリを殺させてみてください
必死で逃げるんですよね
自分の命を守ろうを守ろうと
ですから 仏教でいうのは
すべての生命は平等であると
その生命を尊敬する心さえなければ
もう何にもならない もう不幸ばっかしで
だからすごく捨てがたい気持ちなんです
この差別感というのは
ですから 心から綺麗にこの差別を意識捨ててみてください
それで徹底的に人間付き合いではなくて
すべての生命とうまく付き合うことは何のことなくできるんです
この慈悲の瞑想でそれを教えているんです
徹底的に頭に叩き込んでやろうと
生命の頭に これ毎日念じると
他人に対してこんちくしょうとか思えなくなっちゃうんです
思う瞬間に自分が恥ずかしくなっちゃうんですね
私は偉そうに生きとし生けるものは幸せであります
で何やってるんですかと
あの人を恨んでるんではないかと
なんか自分で恥ずかしくなって
心が軽やかになってしまうんです
僕らの場合は やっとこの他人のこと
外の世界 やっとわかりかけてくると
母親が慈悲のことを教えてくれるんです
たとえ遊びでも 他の生命をいじって遊ぶことはもう絶対許してくれなかったんです
ものすごく怒るんです
怒るときも 私に言われたのは
もう昔の母だからね あなたのために言ってるんだよと一言も言わないんです
あなたはその動物のこと考えたんですかと
あなたにいじめられて
足を折られて 自分の足を折られて他の人を遊んだらどうなるんですかと
うまくこの自分に例えてあった
あの上間かったというこの 3行も出てくるように
自分に例えて叱るんです
ですから 一言で終わっちゃうんです
いちいち言わなかったんです
ほとんど母の声っていうのは
もう聞きたいんだけど
なかなか聞こえないほど静かでしたからね
ですから  もし我々アリなんかを捕まえとすると
あなたのあなたも誰かに捕まれて足なんか折っちゃったらどうなるんですかと
一つ言うだけ それで自分が真面目に考えて
もし人が私を捕まっちゃって足を折っちゃったら
あれすごい痛いでしょうと
足がなくなっちゃったら
まあすごくかっこ悪くて
という気持ちになってきて
すごく怖くなるんです
そこで体の上でアリが飛んで歩いたっても
なんとなく可愛く見て
もう外に出すようになったんです
すごい小さい時から ですから
私はそういう育ちですから
このわずかな差別もものすごくこのもう嫌になっちゃうんですね
わずかな差別で ですから
まあ私も偉そうな説教するんだけど
結構人を批判したりはしているんだからね
で だからうまくいってないんです
私の人間関係も これすごい難しいんです
で どこら辺で人を批判するかというと
もう我慢できなくなるのは
この差別感が一つなんです
わかってはいるんですよ
人間っていうのは完全じゃないんだから
みんなそういう差別感で生きてるんだと
でも育ちが悪くて もうそこだけはすごく
この まあちょっと落ち着くかがなくなっちゃうんですね
なんとか攻撃してやろうと
それは自分のためじゃないんです
決して この差別感 それだけ嫌なんです
それでも聞かないならば
心直らないならば まあ僕もまあその人と付き合う必要ないと
できるだけまあ遠慮する
その芸文で一般的にどのように人間で付き合うべきかということはまあ書かれています
そこにポイントは差別感はいけませんということ
自分が好きなことは他人にすることと
自分が嫌いなことは他人にしないことと
絶対人を裁いてはいけないと
それは聖書にもイエス様が書いているんです
人を裁くな それは大変なこととして書いているんです
それは絶対人間にあってはいけないことであります
で もうちょっと一休みいたします
で 私はあの 日本 あの国へいた昔
あの日本からいろいろお坊さんが来ているのを見ていたんですね
で 自分が泊まっていたお寺にも日本のお坊さんたちが来て泊まっていましたし
そこであの日本のお坊さんだというんだから
まあ服装とか全部違いましたけど
でお坊さんとしてまあ平等に扱って
まあそれなりにまあできるだけのことをしているんです
で 我々の習慣と違って
そのお坊さんたちが この在京の方々が来たら
当然我々紹介するんだから
これは日本のお坊さんですよと言ったら
すごく頭を下げて礼をするんですね
その日本の方々に ただ
このお坊さんたちは すぐその在京の方々にまた合掌して礼をするんですね
そこで子供たちでしたから
僕らにとってはそれすごく面白くて
おかしくて で 隠れて笑っちゃうんですね
何やってるんですかと
そこでどこへ行っても
もう誰に誰にでももう合掌して拝んだりするんですね
それで子供たちがそれを笑いものにしちゃって
で 日本のお坊さんがどこかへ行くと走ってきて一生懸命礼をするんです
なぜかというと その大人が子供たちにすごく頭を下げて手を合わせて合掌する
それはあんまりもおかしくて
結局もう子供たちはふざけて遊んでるんですね
で かえってお坊さんも大変でしたと思いますけどね
どこへ行ってもサーッと人々
子供たちが来て もう一生懸命やってるんだから
日本に来たら 向こうの人々はすごい信仰深くて
まあみるみるところでちゃんと礼をするんだと勘違いしたかもしれませんだけど
結局ガキたちが遊んでいたということだけですけどね
で 私はこれどういうことかとわからなかったんです
それで日本に来て テレビの宗教番組を見ているんだけど
ある日 この禅の番組 お坊さんが来て
この合掌の意味を説明したんですね
ちょっと一言でしたけどね
で 禅宗では相手を見たらすぐ頭を下げて大変丁寧に礼をするんだと
どういうことかというと
相手方は誰でもなく仏様ですと
ブッダですと いわゆる仏様ですと
ですから 自分が仏教の坊主ですから
僧侶だから仏様にちゃんと礼をするんだと
仏様でいたっても普通の人間なんですよ
それ言われた瞬間で あ
なるほどとわかったんですね
意味が それは大乗仏教では全ての生命がブッダですよと
あるいは菩薩神でもありますよと
という この仏教の生命は平等であるということは
もう日本の大乗仏教でも他の大乗仏教でも
それはもう徹底しているんですね
徹底していて それだったら
あれは農家の田中さんですよとかね
そういう気持ちで見てはいけないんです
あれは酪農家の山本さんですよとかね
あれ 山本さんの孫ですよとか
ですから 山本さんの孫でもないし
酪農家でもないし 農家やっている百姓さんでもなくて
見る見るものは全部仏様であると言って
心込めて大変信仰深く
ありがたく礼をするんだということを言ったんでしょうと
で まあそれでは私はすぐそのお坊さんが言ったことはすぐ分かったんで
通じたというか 理解しましたというかね
あ なるほど そういうことですかと
ですから そこで私も勉強して
人に手を合わせて礼をすることは
まあもう何のこともないことだと
それは他人の生命を大変大事に
平等で考えることではないかと
そういう気持ちがね みんな知っているならば
我々にとっては人間と喧嘩できないでしょうに
腹が立つことはできないでしょうに
どんな生命であろうか
何者かとわからないんだから
私たちはちょっと形だけを見て
表だけを見て なんか人を差別しちゃいますけど
そんなものじゃないんです
それで似ている考え方は初期仏教にもあるんですね
初期仏教では 我々は限りなく輪廻転生しているんだと
どこから始めたかということはありえない話で
もう初めがないんだと
ずっと輪廻転生している
それで我々はもうみんな同じく数きれないほど格好で輪廻転生してくるんだから
みんな同じなんですね
今はアリですけど 来世は何になるかわからない
今私は人間ですけど 死んでから来世はどうなるかわからない
ですから人は と生命差別するくことは全くありえないんだと
いけないことだと で 昔の王様たちがいるかもしれませんし
昔過去世で皆様方は神神でいたかもしれませんし
大体みんな同じサイクルを回っているんだから
わずかなでも差別しちゃったら
それは後でも返ってくるんです
生命の中で そういうことで
まあまた休み前のお話の続きなんですけど
やっぱり日本でも仏教の世界ではその概念はちゃんとあるんです
生命は平等であるということ
だから お坊さんたちだけそれは頑張っているんだけど
これはもうどんどんみんなに言わないんですね
堂々と それもごまかしではダメなんです
かっこつけて美しく 行儀正しく
頭を手を合わせて礼をすると
そうじゃなくて 心を合わせて心でやらなくちゃいけないんです
問題は心にあるんです
頭の中で まあどうせ自分が出家だから
ちゃんと手を合わせて合掌して礼をしようという形だけやっても意味がない
形でやらなくたっても
やっぱり心でその気持ちが必要なんです
そこ大乗仏教と我々の違うところはそこら辺なんですね
僕らはもう形ではあまり気にしない
ちゃんと行儀よく礼をしますかとかね
そこはあまり気にしない
手を合わせると 子供たちなんかものすごいいい加減なんです
こうやって手を合わせたりするし
いろいろやり方で でも我々が気になるのは
本当に手を合わせる気持ちがあるかないか
それだけなんです ですから
やっぱり生命は平等であることを
みんなこの手を合わせるべき存在であるということは理解しておけば
まあなんとかうまくいくだろうと思います
で もう一つ お釈迦様の言葉を申し上げます
読み方はな な パレサンビローマニ
このパーリ語はこのローマ字通りに読めば読めるんです
単語ね で読み上げます
な パレサンビローマニ
な パレサンカタカタン
カタアカタン アッタナアヴェ
アヴェッケーヤ カタニ
アカタニチャ この母音の上にちょっと印が入ってます
それはちょっと伸びるんです
ロングワロースというこの 2つあります
もう一度見てください
ネパレサンビローマニ
ネパレサンカタカタン
アッタナアヴェ アヴェッケーヤ
カタニヤカタニチャ それとそのお釈迦様の言葉で原文です
ですから節があるんです
ネパレサンビローマニ
ネパレサンカタカタン
アッタナアヴェ アヴェッケーヤ
カタニヤカタニチャ そういうこっちもまた同じだけ
ナパレサンヴィローマニナパレサンカタカタン
アッタナワアウェッケイエ
カタニアカタニチャ というふうに我々は覚えるんです
まあ節があるんだから覚えやすいんです
ナパレサンヴィローマニ
パレサン 他人のヴィローマニ
過ち おかしいこと いけないこと
他人の過ち おかしいことはね
見る必要はないんだ ね
っていうのは ノー ドント
関係ないんだ 他人の過ち
間違い おかしいことなどなども関係ないんだ
また 二行目 ナパレサン
他人のカタカタン カタっていうのはしたこと
アカタっていうのはしなかったこと
他人のしたこと しなかったことは
な もう関係ないんだ 三行目
アッタナウェ ウェっていうのは強調するんです
自分のこと もうこちらで強調するんです
自分のことこそ アレッケイエ
観察したらいかがでしょうか
観察するものですよと
すごい柔らかい動詞なんです
自分のことを観察すればいかがでしょうかと
これをこうに四行目につなげる
カタニ したこと アカタニ
しなかったこと を観察すれば
気になればいかがでしょうか
人が人の過ち 人がやったこと
やらなかったことを気にする
気にするんじゃなくて
自分がやったこと やらなかったことを観察すれば
気になったらいかがでしょうか
という言葉なんです それもよく人間やることで
我々には他人の過ちはすごく見やすい
自分の過ちは全然見えないんです
で あの この私は引用している法句経なんですけど
このまあ聖書にももうキリスト様
キリスト様の言葉にはもうほとんど言葉通りに似ているところがいっぱいあるんですね
同じ意味があるんですね
同じ意味の言葉はあるんです
で 人間というのはヴィローマニ
あの人はヴィローマっていうのはちょっとおかしいという意味で
あの人はあんなことやった
あれはおかしい これはおかしい
あの人の服装はおかしい
あの人の髪型はおかしいとかね
化粧はちょっと厚いんじゃないかとかね
ああだこうだとか 人のことばっかしなんですね
そこであの人はこんなことやりますよ
のことやりました こういうこともしましたとか
あるいはああいうことをしなかった
こういうことをしなかったとか
他人のことばっかりもう批判
批判とか そういう人間にはもう生まれつきすっごい悪い癖がついてるんです
それで人間関係がうまく行かないんです
なぜならば 我々は人の悪いことを見えことだけ見えるフィルターを持ってるんです
世の中から情報入るんだけど
このあのコスっていうんです
何て言いますか あの腰
それで悪いものだけ入るようにしているんです
人々の悪いところ いけないところ
心の中 すっごく汚れちゃうんです
人と喋ったら あの人は本当にまあ服装は変ですね
色は合ってないんですねとかね
あれ 髪型すごく変でしたよとか
なんか変な言葉ですね
あの人使ってるのはとかね
結局それで自分の心はすごく汚れてるんですよ
その代わりによく見えるのは自分のことだから
あったな わけ 自分のことを見てくださいと
自分が何をしているんですか？何をしてなかったしてないんですかと
そうすると 我々の心は清らかになるんです
自分が治るんです 自分が治ると
他人からは何の問題も出てこないんです
自分がやることを正しいかないかと気になる人ができるだけ正しいことをするんでしょうね
そうすると他の人々は悪いフィルターを持っていても
その人にはなかなかその批判することは見つからないんです
ですから 今日今言いたかったのは
自分が他人に批判されないように
他人に悪く思われ思われないように自分のことを直せば
人間関係がうまくいくということなんです
人を直すんじゃなくて
自分を直す 他を正すんじゃなくて
自分を正す そうすると人間関係がうまくいくんです
それだけのこと 私たちいつも他人を正そうと思っているんです
どうしても努力しているんです
そこで人間関係もうまくいかない
他人を正そうというのは
自分のために自分にぴったし合う性格の人を作りたがっちゃうんですね
そこは人間の人権 権利を侵すことであって
生命の生命としての権利を侵すことであって
この宇宙にその権利は誰一人もないんです
生命は平等だから 生命の王様がいませんだから
だからそれ迷惑なんですよ
生命支配している誰かが偉い
親分がヤクザみたいにいるんだよと思っちゃったら
このなかなか人生は幸福にならないんです
生命を裁く誰かいるんだと
裁く権利誰にもないんです
ですから  私たちはいつでも他人の過ちを見たりするんだけど
それはとんでもない過ちであって
絶対やってはいけないことでありまして
自分を正す 自分を正すと
自分を正しちゃうと 他人が自分とうまくいくんです
自分の希望通りに人を直そうと思うところで
人間関係崩れちゃうんです
もしかすると 皆様の心の中でこれから質問をすると
そのような質問が出るだろうと思いますけど
だから前もってこれ言ってはいけないしね
質問に時間を与えた方がいいんですけど
だいたい出てくる質問っていうのはもうわかってるもんで
もうなんかあの人はこういうことで
こういうことで まあもうどうすればいいんですかとかね
それはやっぱり自分のために他人を正そうとしていることなんですね
そういう同じことであっても
質問したければどうぞ質問してください
じゃあそれで我々は人気がある人間になりたければ育てなくちゃいけない 4つの特色があるんです
人気者になりたければ
みんなに好かれるというんですか
みんなに愛される 使われる人間になりたければ
で  4つの特色がありまして
それ育ててみた方が結構です
それをお釈迦様はこのある人がいて
ものすごい人気者なんです
若者で で どこへ行ってもすごい人一緒にいるんです
もう何 100人も 大勢の人がもうグループで活動しているんです
若者なんです その若者は結構
お釈迦様もまた仏教の人ですから
仏教の経典に名前残っているんです
すごい人気者で 若者で
で なんであの人はあんなに人気ありましたと
なんかみんな問題に考えたんです
そこで大坂様はあの子に釈尊がおっしゃったことがあります
その子はそれをすっごく大事に
真面目に真剣に守っていたんです
一番目はダーナンというんです
これは大乗仏教でも出てくる言葉なんです
ダーマン ダーナンというのは専門用語みたいに聞こえますけど
施しなんですね 施し で
それはこの何かお布施しなさい
寄付しなさいという簡単単純な意味で取っちゃったら意味が消えちゃうんです
で 施し あるいは与える
ですから 皆様方は与えるという言葉をお掛けになってください
与える それを習いましょうと
何を与えるか それはちょっと大雑把にしてください
ただ単に与えると そこで我々はいろんなものを持ってるんですね
それは人間というのは自分のものを自分のものだと思って
この自分だけに従っちゃうんですね
そうじゃなくて 与えると自分が能力を持っている
その能力を他人のために使う
他人に与えてあげる 自分がものを持っている
それも他人に与える 分けると分けてあげると
その人々とうまくつきあうんです
もらう側は決して悪い気持ちにはならない
あの人は毎日ピアノを教えてくれるんだから大嫌いですよとかね
あの人は何か自分の家に美味しいものが入っちゃったら
田舎からすぐ分けてくれるんだから
会いたくもないんですよという人はいませんよ
この世の中で 本当に行儀が悪いんですよという人はいません
あの人はすぐ自分のうちに人を呼んで
私をよく呼んでごちそうしてくれるんだから
本当に嫌ですね 会いたくもないんですよと
気持ち悪い人ですよと
言う人がいません 人間というのは仲良くしたいんです
仲良くするためには何か引っ掛けがなければいけません
そこは与えることから成り立ってるんです
ですから 我々には我々が持っているもの
いろんなものを持ってますよ
それをみんなに与えると
それで大変人生は幸福になるんです
で 例えばこのみんなこの早く金儲かりたくて
この何でしたっけ このそういう芸能関係の仕事に入りたがっている人々
世の中でいっぱいいるんだけど
例えば綺麗な声が持っている声を持っている人は
それはみんなに聞かせてやりたいと
みんな喜ばせてやりたいという気持ちがあって
そこでそういう世界に入って歌手になると
結構楽にお金も入るし
人気も出てくるし でも人気はそんな簡単に出てこない
その声を聞いて人々が喜んだならば
人気が出てくるんです
それはあれは商売の世界ですけど
そちらにもなぜ人気あるかというと
大勢の人に与えているんですね
ですから大勢の人に愛されるんです
この演劇をやっている人々も
同じく女優さんやら俳優さんたちやら
自分持ってる才能はみんなに分けてあげる
それで大勢の人が喜びを感じたらいただいてるんですね
それで その分 その人に対して人気が出てくるんです
それも与えることなんです
その人ごと金取ってるんだからね
嫌がりますけどね まあ人々追っかけてくるの嫌がるんだけど
結局ファンがいっぱいいた方が
その人々にとっては仕事はしっかりするんですね
結局は ですから 我々にも自分が持っている能力を
物であろうか 他の能力であろうか
与えてあげると 他人に使われると親しまれる
2番目はペイエワッジェと発音するんです
ペイエワッジェ それは日本語で愛語と言うんです
愛は愛で 語は言葉 愛語
人間付き合いの場合はものすごく言葉大事なんですね
我々は話し合いで話すことで
かなり人間付き合いっていうのは
喋ることで成り立っているんです
与えるものよりは喋るの方が多いんですね
それだったら愛語 美しい言葉
相手を好きな言葉 相手の心を喜ぶ言葉だけ喋ろうと
いくら腹が立っても 腹が立って言葉を喋ってはいけない
相手が何か間違いを起こしちゃったと
失敗しましたと それで腹が立って何かきつい言葉を言いたくなっちゃうんですね
それそれでもこの言葉を聞いて
この人は喜びますかと考えて
人が喜ぶ言葉だけ喋る
そうすると敵がいませんよ
一人も敵が消えちゃうんです
わかりやすいんだから早く行きます
3番目はアッチャチャリア
それは日本語の言葉は覚えていないんです
と区民の皆様と共に一層力を入れてまいります
あったというのは もう役に立つ意義のある人の役に立つという意味なんですね
チャリアっていうのは行動
生き方 ですから 他人のためになる生き方
してほしいんです いわゆる人に
生命に邪魔するなと否定的に言えばそれなんです
誰にでも邪魔するな 迷惑かけるな
人のためになる 人の助けになることをしてほしいんです
いわゆる仏 いっぱい人間いるんだけど
世の中でいてもいなくてもどうでもいい人々なんですね
あの人いなくては困りますよという人はほとんどいないんです
そうなってほしくない
たまに言われ聞こえるでしょうに
あんたはいなくても大丈夫だよと
あなたはいない方がいいですよと言われる人間だから
そうじゃなくて 我々はできればあなたがいなかったら困りますよと
そう言われる人間にならなくちゃいけない
自分がいなかったら誰かが困るならば
その人がすごく充実感があるんです
子供を育てている母親が子供を育てる間ではすごく充実感を味わっているんです
なぜならば 自分がいなかったらどうしようかということですから
子供も母親が亡くなったら
もういなくなったら大変だと
役に立ってるんだということがよくあるんです
そこで母親がいてもいなくてもいい状態になってきたら
まあどうでもいいということで家を出て行きますけどね
で それはそれだけで止まらないで
我々は生命に対してなくてはならない存在になるなるならば
もう人間関係は問題にならないんですね
で 人間の歴史の中で名前残っているのは誰の名前ですか？立派なお墓作っている人々の名前全然残ってないんです
古墳まで作っているバカがいるんだから
誰の古墳かやっぱりわからない
もう韓国にもありますよ
山みたいに作っちゃって
小さな山なんです どんなバカがその中に骨をそこに置いたか全然わからないんです
ですから もうそれで考古学者たちが必死で研究するんですね
何者かと そんなものを誰だっても
いつ生まれか 何やったかとやっぱりわからない
でも我々は全然関係ないのに
キリスト様はどんなものか
何やってるかそれはよくわかってるし
お釈迦様はいつ生まれてどこ何やってたとか
全部知ってるし で あ 自分の
この昨日も言ったんだけど
自分のひいおじいちゃんの名前なんですか？いつ生まれたんですか？と聞いてもわからないでしょうに
じゃあアインシュタインのアルバートアインシュタインはいつ生まれていつ死んだかと言ったらだいたいわかりますでしょうに
その人はどんな生活でしたか？と言えば
だいたいみんなわかってるでしょうに
古墳は作ってないしね
ですから なんでその人の名前を覚えているんですかね
なんでアーキメデスといったとすぐわかるでしょ？アーキメデスなんですかと
何をやった人ですかと
アイザックニュートンはといえば知ってるでしょうね
ど何人ですか？とかね
アイザックニュートンでお墓でっかいお墓があるんだから知ってるんですか？わかったよ
もうどこに生まれたかも
どこに生まれた なんて言いますか
埋葬したかどうかわからないでしょうに
なんでそういう人々のことを知ってますかというと
やっぱり人間の役に立ったんですね
そうでない人々は こんな立派な
どんな立派な墓を作ったって
後でもうみんなもう忘れちゃうし
迷惑だと思っちゃうし
壊しちゃってその上建物作っちゃうし
で あの このお寺の住職さんに
その方にも聞いたんだけど
この道路を作ってるんだと
あの道路じゃなくて地下鉄で
どんどんお墓とかね 出てくるんだと
そこで仕事を辞めて みんな怖いんだから
お寺に来て まあそれなりにこの供養してもらってるんだと
このお寺のお墓なんですよ
今 地下室作ってるんです
ですから その当時の人々はすごいありがたい気持ちで
まあ真剣になってお墓作ったんだけど
結局もう捨てられちゃう
ですから 意味がないんです
そんなものは 我々は生きている間は人の役に立つこと
わずかでもいいんです
偉大なる人にならなくても
我々は別に偉大なる人になりたいという気持ちがないんだから
自分の周りの人々と仲良く生きればいいでしょう
会社と家族と親戚関係と友達関係
それだけでしょ それだけうまくいけばいいんですから
たまに外国に行ったら
ちょっと行儀が悪いことして
ちょっといろいろやられる時もありますけど
その場合は団体 グループ
団体で旅行すればいいしね
ですからまあ 我々はそんなに大胆なことをなさらなくても
自分の周りの人々の役に立つような生き方をすれば問題ないんです
最後の 4 番目は サマナッタタ
サマナッタタ  SMA 長い A と NATTA TA
長い A ですね サマナっていうのは平等
平等 あったっていうのは自分
で 自分でも他人でも大概自己という意味で
生命 どんな人でも平等でイコールだと
様々等しいんだと その気持ちで生きててくださいと
もし自分に仲間がいるならば
自分が親分で仲間は子分だと思っちゃったら
それは恐ろしいグループなんですよ
みんな同じ仲間だと みんな同じだという気持ちで人と付き合わなくちゃいけないんです
サマナタタ その 4つを守るならば
もう人気者 問題ない 自分が人気者だから
もう決して人付き合いから問題は出てこないんです
僅かにでも実行してみてください
かなりうまくいくんです
ダーナン 人を助けてあげることでしょう
施しですから いろんな方面で人の助けになる
ペイジャワッチャン 自分を喋る言葉はよく考えて
相手が聞いて喜ぶだろうかなと
それ考えて そういう言葉だけを喋る
口にチャックをつけておく
口に悪い言葉ばっかり出てくるんだったら
あまり自分の言葉失礼悪いんだったら喋らなくてもいいんです
笑うだけです 笑うだけで済みますよと
そういう風なコントロールでもして
悪いことを喋らないようにする
批判的なこととか 喋る場合は
人の過ちを見たところで自分が喋らなくちゃいけない
自分の子供が何か間違いをした
会社で部下が何か間違いをした
その時 自分が喋らなくちゃいけない
その時の言葉さえ 相手が聞いて喜ぶ言葉でなければいけません
あ 教えてくれて本当にありがたいと
この人 本当に私のことをすごく大事に考えているんだと
自分で言うならば そこは失敗なんです
私はあなたのために言ってるんだよというのは
もう向こうに嫌われてるんだからなんです
もう正真正銘だから わざわざそんなことを言うんだから
そうじゃなくて 聞かれる
聞か聞かれる側が聞かされる側が自分で
やっぱりこの人 よく私のこと心配してるみたいやと
すごく私のことを大事に考えているんだと思われるように喋らなくちゃいけない
それは人のこと 間違いとかね
部下の間違いは上司が直さなくちゃいけない
子供の間違いは両親が直さなくちゃいけない
生徒たちの間違いは 先生たちが直さなくちゃいけない
それはしょうがないんです
年上の方々は 年下の人々の間違いは直さなくちゃいけない
それは人間の義務ですから
だからといって怒って
これはああだこうだとか言う権利はないんです
自分の間違いを直してくれると
あ このおじいちゃんが本当に優しい人やと
よく言ってくれたんだとありがたいと心に感じるようにしゃべるんです
それはペイジャワッジ
愛護 アッタチャリアっていうのは
自分が人の役に立つような人間になること
サマナタっていうのは平等であることをしっかりすると
その 4つです じゃあ 次のポイントは
我々はどれぐらい人間と付き合うべきかと
ということなんです そこでいろいろ言えるんです
一つは 自分にはコントロールできるくらいの人の数でいいんです
それぞれの人の能力は様々だから
友達がもう 3人いたら十分な人もいて
友達が 10人いてももうまた元気な人もいるんです
ですから 例えば友達が 2人いると
ものすごい十分な人はもう 4人作っちゃうんだと
そうすると自分にはもうなかなか暇がなくて
この対応できなくなっちゃうんですね
それは自分の家で もう経済的にも力もなくて
うちももう部屋も小さくて
もうせいぜい 3人が入って 3人ぐらいにはご馳走できるんだけど 8
人も呼んでしまっちゃうし
そうするともう大変きついでしょうに
それで来る友達に対しても失礼でしょうに
座るところはないわ 食器は足らないわ
もう食料はあまりもうそんなにもう揃ってないわとかに
それはそんな見栄で行動する必要はないんです
自分にはもう思い存分 2人の友達がいれば
もうもうギリギリの状態だったら 2人ぐらいと 10
人いても大丈夫な人は10人ぐらい友達を作るとか
もう 100人でも何のこともない人々は 100人ぐらい友達を作るとかね
そういう自分の能力を知ることですね
ですから たくさんの人がいてもいなくても
それは問題なく 自分にはどれぐらい友達がいるかということは
まあどれぐらい能力があるかということを考えてほしい
それは一つ もう一つは
みんなと平等平等だと言うんだからといって
みんなと付き合う必要はないんです
それを覚えておいてください
それは特別なポイントなんです
仏教はすべての人は大乗仏教だったら
まあ菩薩ですって菩提心を持っているよと言うんだけど
我々の仏教でもすべての生命は絶対的な平等だと言うんだけど
だからといってみんなと付き合う必要はありません
付き合わなくてもいい人々がいるんです
仲良くしなくてもいい人々がいるんです
どういう人々ですかね
もし人々と仲良くすることによって自分が汚れる
なぜなら平等に仲良くしなくちゃいけないでしょ
自分が汚れる 自分が罪を犯す
自分の頭はバカになる
性格は悪くなる あるいは自分が堕落する
もし人と付き合うことによって自分が堕落するならば
その人と付き合う必要はないんです
カットしてもいいんです
それもお釈迦様はしっかりとおっしゃっているんです
大体この付き合うということは
相手の性格は自分に移るんです
たとえ麻薬は嫌いな人であろうが
麻薬を使うグループに入ってすごく仲良くしていると
必ずしも麻薬を使わなくちゃいけない方羽目になっちゃうんです
例えば菜食主義の人がいるんだと
自分付き合った人はみんなまあ肉も魚も全部食べているんだと
そうするとまあどんどん何か仲が悪くなってくるんだから
自分も食べるようになってしまっちゃうんです
だから人と付き合うと
人の影響は確実に受けます
影響を受けるんだから
人を選ばなくちゃいけないんです
平等だと平等でいて またバカみたくどんな人でも付き合うことはお釈迦様は言ってないんです
平等は平等ですけど しかし
輪を作る場合は 自分の心汚れない人々を選んで付き合ってくださいと
もし人と付き合うことによって自分のいけないところを直してしまって
影響を受けて自分が立派になるならば
その人々とお願いしてでも付き合ってくださいと
例えば ある人と付き合うと
自分がどんどんしっかりする
頭は良くなる 性格は良くなる
行儀が良くなる 自分が立派になるならば
その人に迷惑かもしれませんだけど
お願いしてでも お願いしますとか
お願いしてでもその人と付き合ってくださいと
仏教では財産捨ててでも行ってくださいと
はい そういう人と それはこの悟りの場合はね
もし立派な先生に会ったならば
その先生は私はもう帰ります
言っちゃったら 自分のああだこうだと文句言わないで
財産も全部捨ててでもそういう偉大なる人に付き合ってください
それはあなたのためになるんだと
大体立派な人っていうのは
そんなに人を弟子入りはしたくないんですよ
あんまり仲間がいて それで威張りたくないんですよ
人はできているんだから
どうしても仲間作る人々は人はできない
できてないんですよ 人気があってほしいとか
みんなにもう仲良くしてほしいとか泣き叫ぶ人々は
自分の性格できてないんです
だからみんなもう出て行く
もうこの人は嫌ですから
まあちょっと遠慮しようという状態なんです
人はできてくると 別にもう誰が付き合っても
喋っても喋らなくてもあんまり気にしないんです
嫌いがいてもいなくても
ですから 我々の方でお願いします
お願いしますと言って
向こうに迷惑をかけなくちゃいけないんです
優れた人の場合は そういうことで
みんなと付き合う必要はありません
人と付き合うと自分の心は汚れるならば
性格が悪くなるならば
自分が罪を犯すならば
その人々と付き合いはきちんとピタッとカットしてください
どうぞ一人で十分だと
もし一人もなかったならば
一人でいいんだと それは釈迦の教えなんです
いい仲間がなければ一人でいること
孤独 孤独 孤独 孤独でいることは素晴らしいんだと
それだったらうまく成長しないかもしれませんだけど
堕落もしないんですね
ですから 大体こういう国々が発展すると
結構みんな孤独なんですね
一人一人で それで嫌だと悩んだりしますけど
それは本当にみんな人
性格できてないんだから
あまり良くないことなんですけど
でも孤独も決して悪いことじゃないんです
で 自分がもうちょっと性格はまあちょっとだらしないと思うならば
それなりのしっかりした人と付き合った方がいいんです
だけど 今の社会では この女子が言うことを部下が聞きたくない
先生が言うことは生徒たちが聞きたくない
偉そうに威張っちゃって
ああいう性格だから困ってるんですね
それはもう今言ってるのは
この部下の性格 生徒の性格
ですから 我々は自分より目上の人
性格の優れている人がいるならば
そこで自分で行って頑張ってなんとかして付き合った方がいいし
性格の悪い人であるならば
向こう側からもう呼んでも仲間に入ろう入ろうと入ってくださいと呼んでも結構ですと
遠慮しますと言った方がいいです
子供の中でそんな問題あるんですね
仲間が欲しくて もう呼べられるとこ
どこでもいいんだから入ってしまっちゃうんですね
それで後で見たら悪いことをする仲間になっちゃうし
それで抜けられなくなっちゃうし
ですから 母親はしっかり教えてなくちゃいけないんですね
友達は作れ作れじゃなくて
いい友達が作りなさいと
いい友達がなければ 自分一人で頑張ればいいんじゃないんですかと
どうせ人は一人ですからと
一人でいられるぐらいしっかりしなさいと
そこで人が不思議なこと
一人で何でも大丈夫やという状態にいると
結構仲間が出てくるんです
なぜならば そういう人と付き合うことは負担じゃないんです
邪魔にならない その人は何でも一人で大丈夫ですから
迷惑をかけない他人に
ですから しっかりした孤独主義者にはいっぱい仲間がいるんです
そういうことで あの何人に付き合うかという問題は終わります
まあ大体話はもういっぱいありますけどね
言いたいところは で まあここら辺いろいろまあ終わりにしますが
あの最後にこれを言いたいんです
私たちは一番問題になるのは
この人が悪いことをしたらどうし
どうしようかと 批判してはいけないんだったらどうしようかとかね
子供たち叱ってはいけませんかとか
いつでも子供を怒立てた方がいいんですかとかね
じゃあ部下が何か悪いことをすると
では黙ってるんですかと
叱らないで そんな無関心で結構ですかという問題なんですね
そこで仏教で言っているのは
普通の考え方とは違う考え方なんですね
こういうこと 例えば私が何か間違いをする
それで間違いしたことは確かなんですけど
じゃあ私がそれはいちいち言って言われて
みんなの前で言われて批判されるのは好きですか？と
皆様も自分の心に聞いてみてください
もしかすると皆様もいろいろ失敗したことがあると思いますよ
まあ私は結構 まあ自分の人生計算すると
もう失敗 失敗と合格と言っちゃうと
合格の方がほとんどないぐらい
なかなか失敗した経験いっぱいですけど
嫌でもわけないんです
まあ失敗はいっぱいしているんだけど
だからあんたこんなことなんでやってるんですかとか批判されるのは嫌なんですね
皆様も自分の心から心で聞くと
自分たちが何か失敗したことを思い浮かんでみてください
その時はいちいち言われて欲しかったんですかと
それはないんですよ 例えば
ちっちゃな子供が何か大事な食器を取ろうとして
それをもう割ってしまったと
で 子供は失敗したんですね
確実に母親に叱られるんですね
あれ叱られることは嫌なんです
ですから そこは良くない
だから たとえ部下が間違いを起こしても
生徒たちが間違いを起こしても
他の人が何か間違いを起こしても
その場で叱るんじゃないんです
叱るんじゃなくて どのようにこれを教えた方がいいかなと
例えば子供の例で言うのは
僕にとっては簡単ですから
例えば子供は大事な食器を落としちゃって
もう割ったんだと そこで叱るんじゃなくて
何のことなく この物を取る時はこうやって強くつかめますよ
そうすると滑れないんだと
で 他の食器でも他の何かものでも
じゃあこれ捕まってごらん
で それで母親それ引っ張ってみたら
ほら しっかり捕まってないでしょ
ですから もうしっかりと捕まるんだと
と教えたから 子供はそれ勉強するし
子供たちすごい楽しいことになっちゃうし
それは叱ることでもでない人を育てる方法なんですね
で 例えば学校のこの昨日見たんだけどね
まああの目白の駅の前で子供たちがタバコ吸ってるんですね
あの子供たちがもう偉そうにタバコ吸ってるんだけど
僕はちょっと言いたくは言いたくなったんだけど
何も言わなかったんです
関係ないんだから 吸えないんですよ
タバコは 吸えないんだけど
偉そうにタバコを吸う
それでまあもう唾出して出して
全部周り汚くして 自分もすごいひどい顔をして
わさわさと大人になってやると思ってるんですね
で そこでもし先生がいたら
もうもう何やってるんだ
タバコ吸っていけないとかってことで罰するかもしれません
そういう体罰批判あるんだから
あんなことをやってるんです
そうじゃなくて ああ それ吸って本当に気持ちいいんですか？とかね
そんなことをして自分が大人に言うようなことでもバカでしょう
そんなことはね まああんた
どうしてもしっかりしている人ではないかと
タバコ吸わなきゃ大人にならないと思ってるんですか？とかね
そう思ってるんだったらタバコ吸ってくださいと
そういう風に この相手と一緒に物事を考えて
相手が楽しくなるように
面白くなるように 相手の心が相手の権利ですが
生命としての それは絶対的であるということを覚えて
相手は責めてはいけないんだと
そういうふうに言葉を使わなくちゃいけないんです
それはもう知恵がなければできないんです
ですから それはいつでもケースバイケースで
説法では言えないんです
こうしてくださいと いつでもケースバイケースで
その子にはこの方法 この子にはこの方法だと
で その時で実行しなくちゃいけない
そういうふうに この人の間違いを見ても
怒ったり 叱ったり 批判したりはしないこと
その代わりに相手の気持ちを喜ばせながら
正しい方法を教えてあげると
じゃあ正しい方法を教えてあげますと
そういうふうなことをすればいいんじゃないかなと思いますね
で まあそろそろ時間になりましたので
また あの 何でしたっけ
で 最初最後の言葉としてこういうことを言いたい言葉ありましてね
あの すべての生命に対して我々は愛情を持って
すべての生命が尊いだと
人が怒っても私は怒ってやらないんだと
人が間違いを起こしても
私はそれに怒っていちいち言わないんだと
大きな心で 空気のような心で
大地のような心で 海のような心で我々は生きるべきですよと
海のような心というのは
どれほど水が入っても海がそのままなんです
地球の汚れがいくら入っても
海は別になんのこともなくいるんですね
大地というのは同じく
人間が何やろうとも別に気にしない
それぐらいの大きな心を作っていただければ
まあ立派な人間関係になるだろうと思います
それから 人間関係は素晴らしくしようとすることは
単なる社会的な行動だけではなくて
常に私の話でわかると思いますけど
仏教から言えば 常にそれは我が心の修行であります
正しい人間関係っていうのは
私の私個人の修行であって
私の心を清らかにすることであって
私が私自身が立派になることでありますと
ということで終了させていただきます
どうもありがとうございます
[拍手]